teame
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
まずはお土産の定義を読み上げよ一番
旅行先や外出先から家などで持って帰るその土地の産物
2番誰かを訪問する際に持っていく贈り物3番迷惑だもらえものを融合
性病など
思うこと
整備を
ねこれ
道元さを冬休み何か予定あります
シアトルに行きますシアトルいいですねあっお土産買ってください
道元冬休み何か予定あるシーア取るに行く
cheer というかいいねあお土産買ってね
道元冬休み何か予定あるシアトルに行く
シアトルかいいねぇまあお土産よろしく
会って何もいらないからねあ私に入れないからね
じゃあ僕もアップか言って
ここで要注意
最初のいらないからねって言われてしまった時点でオフィス全員分のお土産を買わない
とダメですよってお金がなくてお土産を買いたくないときは
あシアトルにっていう発言もアウトです旅行に行くっていうことさえ
バラしてはいけない代わりにこれらを進める
道元さん冬休み何か予定あるな
セーラームーン全館みるつもりですえセーラームーンティス好きだった後はドラゴン
ボールとなるとかなーっていうかまだカッコイイと思いませんか
僕も忍者だったら絶対に家なんだわかったわかった楽しんでね
ありがとう道元さん冬休み何か予定ある
ない
道元冬休み何か予定あるシアトルに行く
シアトルかいいねぇまあお土産よろしくとか言って何もいらないからね山本さん何も
入れません
了解ですやそのっていうことは妻だけか今回はイムの買ってあげられるねー
道元さん冬休み何か予定ある
僕はないけどやもうとそのままで僕ですか
いやその土産よろしくか言って
あ
田中さんお久しぶりですやビックリしました者のやついいですね
こちらを東京から持ってきました小沢ずすいません
私のほうからもあっありがとうございますいただきます上海から帰りました
現地でこれを僕が買いましてみるでよかったらみんなで食べてください
だからみんな家に開けていないマグカップやタオルがたくさんある
さっき述べた方法はとても便利なら100%効くとは限らないなのでお土産を通しても
買わなければならない時は汚染で
もしくはお酒を勧めするおせんべいに関してはエビが無難な選択肢を避けの場合は
ヨハンリーベ
へと思えること
[音楽]
どうですよ
のみませんか
[音楽]
ん
ぎゅっ度かビールんか
警察です
あなたの患者のリヒャルトブラウンがー
知りました
あ
me
ni